oh they are yeah three sizes too big but
I want though so I got them oh my gosh
I've done that I've done that I was it
was a half size big when I was like
whatever they're so cute it's fine I'll
grow into them you probably will you're
so tall only 16 that's all hey thank you
it's a good thing well so why are bows
your thing
they were my thing too because I danced
and all that crochet that's how that's
actually how they started for me you
know when I was little my mom I mean I
was two years old I was when I was born
actually my mom just kind of stuck him
in my hair and my joke is as I got older
my bones just kept on getting bigger but
but as I realize that bows are really
like a part of my life I realized that I
wanted them to mean something and so
what I came up with is see one a turd
and so if you're wearing a bow or you
see someone wearing a bow that means
that they are a c18 er so say you're you
know at school or you'reyou're don't
have anyone to play with at recess so
you don't have anyone to sit out with at
lunch with ya
if you see someone wearing a Joe Joe bow
you know that you can sit with them or
you know that you can play with them
because that person's a player that's a
safe place that person will be nice if
you are up for it I might have a little
present for you guys I am
all right you a bright vote lots of
rhymes I love that it's yellow too cuz
sunflowers my favorite flower oh there
you go
I'm so anyway here we go watch this I
had to bring your denim denim denim is
my favorite color show on the front okay
that's a real man that's letting you
touch his cowboy hat me at lunch it's
fun it's so kind and it's such a good
thing man is doing is such a huge thing
is social media crazy society we're in
and so that's so cool so how many how
many bows do you have in the jojoba
collection there are over 12,000 yes but
in this last year we sold over 63
million bows that means that there are
63 million people that are being nice to
people 63 million people that are
promising to be kind to be loving to
accept everyone and to be happy or you
have one giant fan that just bought them
all I love it I think it's such a
positive thing and it's so good to
spread kindness and thank you for full
said did do your daughter's rainbows oh
you know I think so yeah Navy doesn't
she barely has any hair oh that was me
yeah she sports that copper vests for
the headband
we got Mo's on advanced yeah well that's
your girl there look at that pink adidas
so you're on a world tour right now yeah
so with what a fans expect from your
show when they come to see it the most
oh my god extravagant most crazy full
out concert you will ever go to like cuz
I put so much effort into my show and
there is so much going on you know
everyone my
she's doing shows is just singing with a
microphone and I was like you know what
I want to put on a full production
proculus it's unbelievable and we just
did 89 cities over the last six what
yeah in January I'm going to Australia
and we're doing seven shows over in
Australia you ever been there it's
beauty I love it love it I want to move
to Australia a little of it's like a
giant Texas I love it I love wishes she
was Australian male or female pizza
person I didn't have a crush on an
Australian for a while I see why yeah
anyway everyone in my audience is going
home with Joe Joe's Bo Club bucks I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this